[Music]
have you
ever seen a face covering like this one
oh a boa constrictor oh is that a snake
is that
a real snake this is a real snake being
used as a face covering or a python
python i don't think they get the
concept of a face covering but
sure it covers my [ __ ] face doesn't
it
right it's like the ladies who had the
the one that was made of like the
see-through stockings
super super thin or john mcafee who put
on
a woman's underwear on his face did you
see that no no you know who that is
right now
of mac defeat mcafee antivirus yeah dude
that dude's wild
dude's a [ __ ] nutter bro how you
pronounce that mcavee
he said that he would i don't even know
maybe right but
pat mcafee is also a puncher for the
indianapolis colts who's super famous
right now because of
uh sports talk but yeah so mcafee
is a super crypto guy now but also put
on women's underwear on his face to get
through
screening and they're like get the [ __ ]
out of here wow
well he was [ __ ] insane though he's
been insane for a while yeah look at
this
i just googled his name yeah dude then
this photo comes out yeah
he's like 76 and uh he
he is a certified nut case but he also
has been
investigated by the government's
government for so long that he's on the
run
yeah dude because he he took over like a
small town in south america or something
like that and like bribed everyone into
his own like private police force and
supposedly like murdered a guy and
that's why he's on the run like he's
living jojitsukawa's dream yeah for real
frankly oh here's the women's underwear
one
yeah yeah right there yeah it looks like
a mask out of glass
oh do you guys see the one where the
women went to the grocery store
and she's like they're like all right
everybody and they pulled off their
underwear
oh and then i think they put on their
face or something to like
test the mask i hope they shower weird
weird
and shaved yeah that's prickly yeah
that's a prickly mask
anyway back to this man with the snake
so
he was spotted on the bus and
he in the uk and so people were just
like
what the [ __ ] because not only did he
just have it on his
face the snake he also let it just get
on the handrails
oh that's uncomfortable that's not on
your face anymore yeah and his face is
exposed
and it's also getting all the stuff
that's on the hand rail and it's gonna
go back on his face
that's disgusting like a coronavirus
collector can snakes get coronavirus
i mean if dogs can probably
true good point very good an excellent
point
and the scientific point even if we
weren't in a pandemic i wouldn't want to
even with my own hands wouldn't want to
touch the handrail and then touch my
feet yeah
the snake itself is not very clean like
we had a snake and
uh are they nasty you should like wipe
the snake down
and then like if you're gonna have them
on you you should wipe yourself wait
don't they clean themselves like dogs do
with their little tongues
all i know is that that takes a long
time yeah
because then like when when the snake
they have plenty of time by the way
that's true
when the snake is eating it's wrapping
his entire body around the
freaking mouse it's dead it's gross you
have like
rat juices but they get rid of their old
skin they're like that's dirty
they shut it yeah that's true that's
true eventually that's true they do
that's how they clean themselves a
little baby skin
but so unless you're gonna be having
your snake right after like on you right
after it sheds
i think that's gross that's not a very
sanitary thing have you guys seen the
one where the
boa constrictor eats a crocodile and
then it explodes because and the
crocodile like
no falls out of its body no i didn't see
that [ __ ] crazy
still alive no it died but it's crazy it
explodes
so two animals died it bursts open
because it ate a
[ __ ] croc that's crazy and yeah it
was too big for it
but the croc died as well too yeah do
you remember that do you remember that
dude that was going to try to get eaten
alive by like a snake or whatever
yeah just like he like started and then
he didn't even like
start and then he like bitched out he
was like no i can't do it i'm getting
anxiety i'm wigging out i'm wigging out
i'm getting claustrophobia yeah i was
like you wanted to get in alive like i
said
also die or just to get in there no just
to get in there i don't know how you
plan to get out or whatever
like a knife a thousand percent died
because it's crushing the bones
well so then he was like he got in this
[ __ ] like
like like environment suit thing with
like a mask on and like air and
everything so
but and then he was going to try and get
the snake to like swallow him whole or
something
by the way why couldn't david blaine's
new stunt be that cool
because his new stone's just like i'm
gonna let balloons take me to the
heavens and we're like so what
it's so boring he's like yeah it's a
four hour video where i
go up in balloons and then i put on a
parachute and calm down
i think people do that for fun anyway
right like it just sounds like a thing
that you like
that's his newest son yeah it's called
ascension it was very boring
look i love david blaine i love david
blaine that's why i'm like that was kind
of boring
but the crocodile eater guy had a better
call yeah yeah i mean i
i searched the video i was like i wanna
see what happens and i was like
yeah that's it
fulfilled this is from 2014. snake guy
or the crocodile eating snails oh the
snake guy
oh snake it was a discovery channel that
aired
a trailered eden a live show so they
just they just aired a video of a guy
chickening out yeah pretty much
a guy being eaten alive by a giant and a
queen at first they aired the trailer
750 times
that's dude that's why i tuned it they
don't stop bro
they're like we're promoting a [ __ ]
oh crazy it's not gonna be david blaine
so
go ahead he's saying that he's getting
squeezed
squeezed by the by the anaconda what am
i looking at
i don't know what oh yeah so then the
doctors are like we're pulling them out
we're pulling them out
yeah oh i see yeah i don't know
that's crazy i didn't understand this
because i was like what did you
expect to happen that looks pain he's
like oh this hurts actually
he's like we hired a bunch of doctors
and people who know what they're doing
kind of
and we're going to try it that's
basically what this was yeah
because they pulled the blog on it so
fast yeah cause he was gonna get hurt
like no [ __ ] [ __ ] so like wait how
much pressure's going on his body that's
crazy
and the snakes are [ __ ] powerful
right yeah
yeah man that was just a super
disappointing tunic
i hired a bunch of experts off of
fiverr.com yeah look look this is the
moment he calls it
two minutes in my arm's twerking yeah
nothing's gonna break call again i need
help
you just rush for it somebody come
oh damn oh is that how they get rid of
mount they just start pulling on the
snake yeah i guess so
was the guy being swallowed by a snake
getting crushed he was supposed to be
that first
his head was in first and then i think
the um the snake was just wrapping
around his body and then he couldn't
feel anything in his arms
i see was he was he a snake expert
himself though i think he was just
because like i don't know if he realizes
how
snakes eat right i think they crush you
first
into a million pieces he went cheap on
the research process he did but i
imagine like he hired a doctor this is
the doctor was like yeah i don't think
this is a good idea but yeah sure i'll
be there
wow i don't know we're like a
bulletproof vest or something
[Laughter]
you believe this is a two-hour special
yeah it took
me forever is it just an hour and fifty
minutes of build-up
yes yes no way
so it says at least david copperfield
made the statue of liberty kind of look
like it disappeared
like with two hours of building so it
was 90 minutes of
him and his team just searching for the
snake followed by half an hour of them
enticing the reptile to consume him
followed by two minutes have been
pussing out
yeah legit legend this guy's a legend
hey aren't you that [ __ ] snake guy and
he's like yeah
you know yeah you want to go inside
something my arm's getting torqued
this one says hey discovery can i get my
own show
eating alive it's a dog biting a finger
that's so good so hey do you remember
uh chris angel mind free mind freak
he had a show in vegas for all but i was
watching his um his like old
videos because then subaru like can you
believe how bad this show was and i
don't remember it being that bad and
then i
watched it again i was like holy [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] awful there's one where
he's supposed to like [ __ ]
jump over the grand canyon in like a
rocket car or whatever
and then and then when it gets to the
part where he's like it's gonna be a one
take we're not gonna cut away from this
so that you can see everything and then
when he hits the ramp he cut to like a
million
no no and then he suddenly like is
behind the car goes over or whatever
and then he just appears behind the crew
he's like wow imagine that like
what he's like we're only going to cut
to 14 angles yeah
you know now he's 52 years old chris
angel is yeah
took him the [ __ ] apart have you seen
penn and teller talking about him i'd
have it
stalking um just that that you know hack
or whatever
yeah it's it's like hey uh bewitched was
like just the same as this show
basically
like it's just it's a did they do it on
[ __ ] or do they do it on like a
he was on a podcast oh yeah danny has a
hot wife
yeah he's mind freak yeah he's my freak
he might freak out how would you feel
very attractive oh wow very attractive
right cute kids too
watches that make him disappear watch as
i pull
the arms off of my son and then like a
little person runs out
did you guys watch that one no what
dude he did one where he was like gonna
cut a woman in half
and then he had a little person like run
out from her disemboweled body or
something
and it was just like you clearly just
had like a little person ready
can you believe the kind of [ __ ] they
were able to get away with
camera tricks are magical bro but that's
why like penn jillette's like look dude
like what
we do is magic what he does is just like
tv sitcom [ __ ]
movie magic yeah movie magic their
[ __ ] show is really cool though i
love that show
it's my favorite show i like the way
they talk about the tricks and like the
the mastery behind it and stuff it feels
like the wait was it is it [ __ ] or
was it no [ __ ] can you can you fool
me yeah i like [ __ ] a lot but can
you fool me as the one i think where
they're taking apart
i like that because it's like they it's
both
kind of like the show in vegas you know
they acknowledge that everything's fake
but it's so good that you can't tell
it's fake and no idea
because they acknowledged it it seemed
it's way cooler though yes
and if you watch their show uh now fool
us or whatever
yeah where they get magicians on the
show that's cool yeah and they try to
it's so cool because they do this moment
where the magicians are just talking to
each other as magicians like with
magicians speak
and the audience has no idea what the
[ __ ] they're talking about but they're
they're both like they both see a trick
and they both see how the trick was done
and we're all just like that was
incredible magic is real
what i mean but they're like you know
you notice you used a force and like
when you use the force and like all the
[ __ ] and like we all know that that
means a force it's like
you basically take a card deck and
you're forcing the person to pick a
certain card
but we don't even know that that happens
what it's incredible i was like
wait so then what's the difference
between a magician and an illusionist
the same it's all [ __ ] that's what
penitential point out yeah
but but when you see a like pick a card
any hard they're
determining what card you need to pick
which is how they tattoo it on their arm
and all the stupid [ __ ] that they did
really is that what they do yeah
cool so like if it's like hey tiff pick
a card
and then you say stop right they already
know which card they're going to
get to by the time you say stop so they
just make it all happen you know for
someone that doesn't like magic
magicians
you know a lot about magic here yes how
did that happen
you have to know what you hate so you
can defeat it it sounds to me as if
a young stephen green once tried to
become a magician
failed miserably and spent his entire
life afterwards
hating magicians dab i can imagine young
steve
in like a little suit with a little red
flower and then he has
like a fake thumb yeah or like we're
like
like yeah the cane thing that like turns
into like a bouquet of flowers
do you ever have a pet rabbit it was all
i wanted to be
[Music]
[Music]
you